cent mille morts dus coronavirus un
triste chiffre franchi en france depuis
le 15 avril en cap qui a été annoncée ce
jeudi par santé publique france dans son
bilan quotidien bien après l'institut
national de la santé et de la recherche
médicale qui évoquait déjà ce cap
fatidique depuis plusieurs semaines
comme nous avons pu la prendre en
consultant les données encore partielles
publiées le 9 avril et présenté par le
directeur de recherche de l'inserm de
façon délibérée ou non santé publique
france semble minimiser c'est le nombre
de décès est un temps de la sorte
passage de ce cap fatidique des 100
mille victimes
djokovic 19 dans l'hexagone alors qu'une
institution publique de santé révèle
progressivement et rapidement le nombre
de défaites au quotidien ou presque du
côté de l'inserm on préfère jouer la
carte du recul et d'une meilleure
précision à l'inserm ce à partir de
l'ensemble des certificats de décès
rempli par les médecins que ces chiffres
sont déterminés ils permettent ainsi les
études par sexe et par tranches d'âge
mais aussi selon la zone géographique de
l'ensemble des victimes
une technique et qui expliquerait
l'écart de plus de onze mille 17 entre
les deux organismes pour la période
allant du 1er mars au 31 décembre 2020
il y à déjà 75 1732 certificat
mentionnant le kobe 19 comme cause
initiale ou associés de la mort au 31
décembre 2020 le tableau de bord de
l'épidémie de santé publique france
faisait lui état de 64 1632 décès
toujours selon l'inserm le sidikou
systèmes d'information pour le suivi des
victimes bénéficient d'une surveillance
qui contiendrait plusieurs angles morts
est responsable de cet écart de données
avec l'inserm
par exemple elle ne tient pas compte des
morts à domicile ni même ceux survenus
dans les unités de soins de longue durée
environ 30 min sur l'ensemble du
territoire ce qui a pour double effet
non seulement de réduire le nombre de
morts mais également de vastes et le
nombre de victimes ayant été contaminées
en milieu hospitalier
les décès survenant aux urgences dans
les services de psychiatrie de soins de
suite et de réadaptation ne sont pas
bien dénombré ce qu'ils sous-estiment
beaucoup de cas nosocomiaux les caves et
donc bien avait
les révélateurs d'un dysfonctionnement
dans le décompte et le fonctionnement du
speed et des décès dans cette épidémie
on devrait pouvoir communiquer avec
fiabilité sur les décès de la veille
la solution serait simple rendre
obligatoire pour tout médecin la
certification électronique des décès
dans les 48 heures même si pour
l'exécutif ce cas des cent mille morts
vient juste d'être atteints il
semblerait malheureusement que ce
chiffre soit déjà dépassé selon l'inserm
qui pointe du doigt santé publique
france dont les données semblent
largement sous-estimées s'agit-il d'une
volonté du gouvernement de présenter un
bilan plus favorable
afin de se prémunir des critiques dans
sa gestion de la crise sanitaire ou ce
décalage n'est-il que technique
imputable au mode de calcul employée
difficile d'en avoir la certitude mais
de nombreuses voix s'élèvent pour
réclamer la généralisation de la
certification électronique de décès
autrement dit la dématérialisation du
certificat d c'est traditionnellement
édité par le médecin qui mettrait fin à
cette bataille des chiffres des plus
morbides